[Applaudissements]
emmanuel macron en tête au premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle avec 27 84%
des voix dans les yvelines les
représentants locaux se sont réunis à
les lier aux pubs à versailles pour
suivre les résultats c'est des résultats
qui sont plutôt bons on est plutôt
contents du résultat des manuels des
résultats d' emmanuel macron ce soir il
montre que la mobilisation de terrain
c'est la force dans marche c'est 28 %
soit un message d'espoir voilà comment
je le prends et donc j'en suis très fier
je crois aussi que ça nous envoie un
message ce que doit être la la façon de
faire de la politique aujourd'hui je
crois que les français attendent de nous
encore plus d'humilité encore plus
d'efforts et encore plus de vérité ce
qui voter emmanuel macron ont répondu
présent donc ce soir même si rien n'est
fait et même s'il faudra faire une
grosse campagne de second tour on est
plutôt satisfait mais encore une fois
rien n'est fait le candidat la
république en marche arrive également en
tête dans le département avec 33 points
41% des votes yvelinois je ne pensais
pas faire un aussi grand pas en avant
par rapport aux résultats de 2010 est
donc en 2017 la sirc hauteur moyenne à
29 % et là je pense qu on est largement
au dessus 40 % puisque j'ai que des
villes hôtes ou de 45 pour un stand
sur place des dizaines de militants
étaient au rendez vous pour fêter ce
premier pas ravi du résultat est soulagé
toujours un peu de doutes ans et une
élection présidentielle donc c'est les
français qui choisissent mais bon on est
quand même content du résultat et puis
même si elle doute on reste motivés et
on était tous là pour se retrouver
forcément heureux par rapport au score
28 % du coup ça s'est passé le travail
aussi qui a été menée par tous les
militants alors du coup que parce
qu'avant dans les yvelines mais on a été
vraiment tout temps sur le terrain dont
on va dire que c'est une belle
récompense on est soulagés mais que
macro emmanuel macron soit vraiment
devant marine le pen la campagne de
l'entre-deux tours est lancé militants
et élus se mobilisent pour cette
dernière ligne droite au programme dans
le département beaucoup de terrain porte
à porte et tractage